Al habba did a bad job representing the
world's worst client in his defamation
trial resulting in an 83.3 million
verdict against the former president but
what if habba wasn't actually
incompetent what if she's actually been
an undercover super agent all along
that's a question being posed by MAA
influencers qu I don't trust Alina Haba
I believe she's a deep state plant just
like Jenna Ellis they've been preventing
Trump from hiring competent Council the
entire time and when he does find
Council they all seem to be incompetent
or corrupt this is planned now I'll
remind you Jenna Ellis was another one
of Trump's failed experiments from the
land of Misfit lawyers Ellis recently
pleaded guilty to aiding and abetting
false statements and writings for her
role in the Georgia election fraud case
now Alina hbas said she'd rather be
pretty than smart because you can fake
being smart but the truth is you just
can't fake being a good lawyer and it
seems her client Donald Trump agrees now
Trump is interviewing lawyers to appeal
the $83 million Carrol verdict quote any
lawyer who takes a trump case is either
crazy or a true patriot I will make my
decision soon well why not both which
reminds me if you need a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can take care of it
just click below